this is a production of Cornell
University
so yeah I'm gonna I'm really excited to
talk to you about a little of the
research that I've been doing the last
four years and a half here and
everything will go around this idea of
using functional genomics to help
dynamic prediction dynamic selection
models in Kassala okay and back in 2013
I was about to get interview by John
Luke through Skype and I had no idea
what dynamic selection was so I started
looking at the literature and what I'm
pretty sure happened with most of you
trying to approach genomic selection
we're haunted by this scheme that I
don't even need to explain this however
at the time didn't help me to understand
these models were working so I came with
a scheme out of my own briefly you have
phenotypes and genotypes of a training
population and combining these two
elements you will build a prediction
model but here I'm depicting it as a
wormhole because I didn't have any idea
what was happening here so what I did
know was that the DNA of a none
phenotype Kesava was traveling through
space and time to give us genomic
expected breeding values that is
basically your expectation or your
prediction on how that unfiltered
cassava is gonna perform on the future
okay so what I did understand at the at
the moment was that my mission within
the project was to use functional
genomics as a proxy to understand the
biology behind the phenotype that we're
trying to predict and see where and you
know try to test whether the inclusion
of this extra element in the prediction
model will be a positive one okay so
today I have three topics for you we'll
go through all of them but yes important
things that all of them will go around
this idea of this
in biology dynamic prediction models so
again but button on 2013 IIE is you know
I was neon cassava and I went to the
databases trying to find genomic
information and casaya was a really
orphan group they're wearing a lot of
genomic resources or genomic research
than other time i was really interested
in working with biotic stresses so I
went to a database
checking for resistant genes in cassava
and I couldn't find it so with Martha
the time we throw it as an opportunity
to both get these that is that mine and
contribute a little bit to the growing
genomic libraries of cassava so we
identify this family of game the NBA
star family that is known to be the
biggest resistant in family in plants we
did some phylogenetics and most
importantly we mapped them into their
position of the in chromosome and this
data later helped other scientists to
make sense out of their game was results
for example this is a publication by
Ismail Kondo a collaborator he found a
couple of of QTL or brown string disease
one of them being in chromosome 11 and
you have to believe me here what it used
to mean he on day on the pick it
collocates nicely with a small cluster
of NBA cell erogenous and some
collaborators from Kenya now are
evaluating using knockouts with pre
spare and complementation assays - you
know validate these candidate genes as
they resist so yeah that's
nice and again that was polished in 2015
but the years passed and Kisame stopped
being an orphan crop suddenly in the
span of two or three years there were
lots of research going on we have a nice
haplotype mild thanks to remove and the
batter lab plenty of transcriptomics
studies a better genome with a really
nice rnaseq guided a notation we have
even methylation data and a plethora of
tools so from now on we switch a little
bit from doing the you know the genomic
resources generator to be more like data
scavengers and try to use all these to
put them in the indigent prediction
frameworks okay let's make a stop here
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
which models we'll be using in the rest
of my talk spoiler alert we won't be
used in any fancy Bayesian or machine
learning algorithms we what we will be
using is just different modifications of
the good old model okay for those that
don't know what you like model is
basically a mixed model feed on the
basis of individuals rather than but
using a covariance matrix that is
calculated as the genomic relationship
okay
and this incorporate is genetic random
effects you basically calculate the year
I am using all the markers available in
2014 however this group from a surprise
and safe and company we're interested in
studying how splitting or partitioning
the genomic regions into functional
elements let's say Colin radios UTA
radians from other videos would
influence this model and as you know
develop models and any model that will
with most of the models that will work
with with engineered predictions where
we have lots of predictors and a few
individuals have
we'll find a way how to deal with
collinearity and overfeeding so GTL
abuse shrinkage we're all most of the
snip effects will are random and our
Shrunk it towards zero and this
shrinkage severity will be a function of
the numbers of his needs in the model
the idea of these guys was what if we
partition the genome in different random
effects genetic random effects and I'm
from now I'm just gonna call these guys
as Colonel and if one of these kernels
is enriched for coastal variance due to
biological priors I have this might
result in an increase in prediction
occurs why because if you are relaxing
the shrinkage severity you are allowing
more markers into that partition having
a vigorous okay so this is basically the
rationale that I'm gonna use on the
models playing throughout my
presentation
the second nice thing well useful thing
about this research was that a goose a
fan collaborators determined that we
need to have level sequence imputation
when you are using dynamic partitioning
methodologies basically the estimation
of is a percentage of any hurt abilities
will be really bad if you just use
genotype is in comparison when you use
genotype holding on imputation mark okay
so yeah this is a little of the
background that we will be going on so
just keep this in mind now the second
topic that I want to talk about is the
the the actually a case study how my
first approach to use biology to improve
genomic prediction as I told you it was
really interested in working with a
diseases abiotic stresses so casts
around a strict disease was really
attractive to me so in this study I
tried to use whole genome imputation and
a transcriptomics study show you to
increase the performance of this model
just briefly cassava brown string
disease goes like a sovereign's trick
virus and it's a really awful disease
okay symptoms in leaves you have
chlorosis on the secondary veins but the
most important thing is that you have
root rot on the tuber that make them
inedible even for animal feed and they
are transmitted by white flies in
persistent way okay so that's that's our
model now so let's go back to my
previous scheme and I'll show you how
I'm gonna incorporate the different
elements into this case so for example
the phenotypes evaluated now will be
cvsd related traits measure on leaves
and roots three months six months and
one year after planting
genotypes will be GBS marcus's will be
imputed given sequence the wormhole
prediction model will be a multi-car and
the the genomics data will be
transcriptomics studies util information
and related traits okay so now let's
plane a little bit of each of these
components in the phenotypes we use
we're basically on leaves and roots a
categorical in rows from 1 to 5 our high
throughput phenotype in scheme
Alfred is here ah da da da the
phenotypes okay the genotypes we
recognized with this was safe paper the
necessity of going from 40,000 markers
that we were obtaining a with DVS to
millions of markers through whole genome
imputation and how was this possible
it's not a lot that we are inventing
markers that were in type we use this
scheme of all denomination that uses the
Hofmann that was produced by the buckler
lab 241 individuals including cultivated
cassava while hybrids and while cassava
relatives and those were deep sequence
238 so we have a nice haplotype maps of
those 204 individuals and while we are
performing here is that when we have GBS
we have a bunch of markers but we also
have a lots of interrelation those of
sites that were missing and what the
whole genome imputation algorithm does
is try to infer which of these regions
we a belongs to which of these
haplotypes and gate most importantly
they the boundaries
once it has the most probable haplotype
of each region it will just until the
missing genotypes with the ones present
in the hub and that's how you go from
CVS or
markers to millions of markers using
this hubbub information and now you will
tell me your word you don't need
millions of marker to perform a genomic
selection we all know that the problem
was that him in my approach I was
interested in Italian different videos
in the genome that might be important
and then if I use only the 42 K markers
from DVS I could only touch around 30%
of it then if I did be real imputation
imputation I get to 70% and finally I
stopped with impute - that is for me at
least a verified you know impute a
l'heure and I could get markers that
will be tying close to 92% of it so
that's the only reason why I keep this
this this methodology together with
those information from the elusive paper
so yeah now we have phenotypes we have
genotypes we need a population for this
our population this is a graph of the 18
chromosomes and including the eldest or
the mean LD score you don't know what I
mean LD score is just do graph each
marker and then calculate the R square
of that marker with all the markers in a
beam of one mega base and then you
divide that by the number of markers in
that beam and you plot all of them and
it gives you a sense of local LD
patterns you can see here a cassava has
like a funky pattern of hi LD close to
the telomeres but there is a second here
I'm plotting this a classical indicate
the only thing that I'm doing
differently here is that I'm coloring
chromosome 1 and chromosome 4 in a
yellow and red respectively because they
have fun recent integration that doesn't
have a lot of recombination so that's
why what is dragging this this funky LD
putter
hi our squares even when the markers are
position really far away in the group
okay so we have markers with the
phenotypes we have a population and this
is our bio biological data okay this a
transcriptomics a study was performed by
Teddy amuse and polish in 2017 and she
basically grabbed two contrasting
genotypes Nami conga resistance to Susie
and Albert's really susceptible and she
grafted these varieties with infected
science and non-infected science and
evaluated differentially gene expressed
across seven different angles six hours
after grafting 24 hours after grafting
48 hours and so on until 54 days and
what we observe here is that the
resistant plant in yellow has a lot of
differential expression she's really
aware that it's been infected while they
Albert's plan insusceptible has like a
really mild response at 6 hours and then
nothing non difference between the the
transcriptional pattern between the
control and the infected ones in all
these time points it just start reacting
when it's it's basically too late so
then we we start thinking how can we use
distress photonic data
wait the genomic prediction models and
we had several hypotheses the first
hypothesis was just brute force so yeah
let's just use all the differential
expressions and compare the accuracy
that we have through the whole genome
imputation this is the full model I will
always be comparing the accuracies with
the full model at the last column this
is cvsd measure on leaves six months
after planting and this is measuring
roots and the model that we are running
here is a to colonel model one of the
colonel will cover all these needs that
are differentially expressed genes and
the other a colonel will have the rest
of the everything so as n
force approach usually happens it didn't
have a good result the prediction
accuracies were basically similar as
they the ones when you will just use the
whole genome imputation full data set
then we generally we try to be a little
bit smarter about it and we had this
idea that maybe those genes that have a
positive interaction between genotype
and inoculation status inoculation
status beam if the plan was control or
inoculated could have a better effect a
major effect on day on day on the
resistance phenomena so we fit this
model where expression the gene
expression of each genes will be
explained by rapes plus a three-way
interaction of genotype inoculation
status and time
and we extracted those genes Loreen here
that had an positively significant
interaction between G by I okay
um similar to the last a picture we
calculated yet Nam ik accuracy the
prediction accuracies for this model in
rate we have they a three colonel model
that was filled with these G by I games
partitioning two chromosome 11
chromosome four and the rest of the you
know here we also incorporated the fact
that we know that in chromosome 11 and
or there were big big to deal okay and
we also fit a model with random a random
genes in the same a proportion and what
we saw is that our model is doing better
than random for separating leaves and
roots but we are know still not doing
better than when test using the basic
development so yeah now the second
hypothesis didn't quite will work yet so
then we have a third hypothesis but if
state of using the differential express
genes we just use a clustering method
whole genome now we're 18 co-expression
network analysis to try to mine
important games unless focusing in this
part of the of the slide the colors are
a little off but it's fine too
better idea of what weighted yuko
expression middle or analysis is doing
it yes it's just clustering genes that
have a similar expression pattern and if
you go today to the black model here and
you'll have to believe me because the
colors are off this black module has
genes that are expressed only in the
enemy conga genotype and then we have
another tsiyon module that are mostly
expressed in Alberts
okay this should be way rather more read
the colors are a little off but anyway
we get a bunch of modules with this
technique and again we try our technique
of two turns
let's get the genes that are within our
module and everything else in the genome
and compare them with the last column
that will be they not very good results
the only one that was doing better than
the whole a model was this model rates
and only for three months so no really
good results of it at the time so we
come up with a four hypothesis that was
basically desperation and
mix different sources of information
trying to beat the performance we hold
in our imputation and we did it but with
you know from ranging from one point six
seven to two point five percent overall
prediction accuracy so it wasn't a big
game but it was a little game and we
have several options why this approach
didn't work as as we were expecting
there is a thing of the trade a genetic
architecture these cvsd resistant in
these populations have big qtls
and may be trying to mine information
out of the RNA seek data is not really
viable because of those two bqp else our
imputation accuracy was performing a
half map that only 140 individuals there
is issues with a phenotype in platform
they transcriptomics experiment it was
only performing two varieties that might
not be representative of the population
and we're working him and finally they
the transcriptomic experiment was used
it was infected using only one strain of
the virus not with the two and what
usually happens in feeling reality that
there is a co-infection of Ugandan
cassava and streak virus and cassava
Brown Street
ok ok ok
hmm what was sorry
yeah one of the things that was also
disturbing me until that point was that
we were only looking for important genes
all important regions within the genes
and the gene gimmick region is only a
tiny part of the whole genome for the
hotel genome there are functional
elements happen outside of the genes and
yeah the motivation for doing this third
part of this is work it was this article
during a raid on 2014 by Manolis Kellis
from the encode project there was a lot
of troubles because the guys from the
ink could say 80% of the human genome is
transcribed so 80% of the human genome
is functional no and then there were
lots of the evolutionary you cannot say
that because you are not under the light
of evolution that can be true I mean the
the guys from encode found evidence for
80% of the Y in the human you know it
was transcribed but we also have to
consider all the Arabians we have
genetic evidence that is basically that
that generate phenotype what you find
when you run a new was and you have also
evolutionary evidence meaning that
regions in the genome that are
constrained by evolution are more
probable probable functional so yeah in
in the like so is this I was also
interested in trying to find functional
elements outside of the cassava genome
so that brings up to this expanding the
cassava functional genome using pro C
and valine 2015 journalist from Cornell
biotech published this article that kind
of exciting me a little bit she was
doing this nascent RNA sequencing and
the important thing you need to know
about these nation techniques is that
allows you to sequence the RNA that are
inside a nucleus
so you can sequence the mRNAs before
being spliced but you can also sequence
all those unstable RNAs that are later
degraded in the in the cytoplasm okay
and by doing that John and collaborators
found that in promoters for example my
him that this is your promoter your gene
is this part of course you have a
transcript going on the only side of the
game but what he found was that that
there was an unstable RNA also being
transcribed on the opposite direction
more importantly she discovered that in
enhancer regions outside of the genes
there was a similar pattern surrounding
the the enhancer will be transcription
of of small RNAs in both directions and
those RNAs will call enhancer RNA the
next year
Charles Danko in collaboration also with
Alan cylinder list publish this Dirac
method it was a machine learning a super
vector regression machine that will
allow you to based on that nasan RNA
sequencing identify transcription
regulatory elements including promoters
and enhance and that's what I believe
hey maybe we can apply this idea to
cassava and identify enhancers that
might be important to explain phenotypes
outside of of the games so I was super
excited with John we were starting to do
the planning and everything and in 2016
they publish this article in using nests
and RNA in Arabi Topsy's and it was the
first study that was performed on lunch
and it was really disappointed at the
time because they say you know in plants
there is lack of Ahaz rnase lack of a
directional transcription lack of
promoter proximal posting i plants are
completely different than mammals and
other metazoans
so I was really sad because we were in
the middle of an experiment trying to
identify these enhancers
using the enhancer RNA is that according
to these people were completely absent
in plant but you know we were in the
middle of the experiment so we just kept
going yeah
so I'll explain a little bit of this
meta-gene clothes so this is what would
happen in the human around the
transcription start site so this is
where they polymerize the first attaches
and then start transcribing back in this
direction so you'll have the
transcription of the RNA and this peak
at the beginning is called the posting
phenomenon okay so we're basically the
polymerases are attached to the
beginning of the in and they are just
waiting for an additional stimuli to
start transcription so and also there is
this bi-directional transcription on the
stable RNA in the opposite direction in
our ovide offices however they observed
two things there is no posting
they're just transcription and there is
no bi-directional transcription okay so
we were in the middle of experiment and
I feel that sometimes when you try to
understand a new molecular technique the
better thing to understand is go through
the protocol so I will just walk you
guys through the protocol a little bit
so grow speaker Pro see our it goes for
global or precision random sequencing
and what this means a methyl down it
does is it will sequence RNA that are
attached to the polymerase
inside and so you start with a cleansing
here then you have to
nuclei so you will only have the nucleus
and you go up here once you have the
nucleus you disrupt the nuclear membrane
remove the nucleotides the arena and
nucleotides and put lots of biotinylated
entities into the solution and then lay
the conditions of the cell culture so
that the polymerase can will be able to
incorporate these nucleotides at least
two positions okay then since those
entities are biotinylated you will just
use a stripper reading with read those
and then you just create follow the
steps to create a regular nds library
you will end up with the strand-specific
nascent RNA seek libraries so first
result we wanted to check if was that if
the things of Surfing arriv'd offices
were the same as we were observing
cassava and the first thing that we have
service at the cassava nascent RNA
profile around the transcription start
site is a hybrid between our video
system see there is posting it means by
this peak but there is lack of
bi-directional transcription if
go to the termination side or sorry the
polyadenylation site at the end of the
gene then we see that the cassava
profile looks quite similar to the
reveals profile and when the humans
don't have this pic at the end of the
games so if we you see the start of the
a gene looks like this if you look for
the end of the game it looks like this
when one of the things that that the
arrival of these people say that was
that there are no pausing in plants and
then in cassava we found Ossining plants
then they say there is no bi-directional
transcription and I kind of saw this
little bump here and say okay let's try
to find some genes that might have this
bi-directional transcription and of
course I found some examples that have
it this is an IDE image of the iron is a
nascent RNA secretes the gene is going
in that direction you have the posting
peak and the transcription but you also
have this bi-directional transcription
in the opposite direction so they
reversed by directional transcription at
least in cassava in a way less amount
than what was observed in humans but
there wasn't so I asked myself like what
if if cassava can have bi-directional
transcription missing some genes may be
there so i annotate peaks in intergenic
regions first using chromatin
immunoprecipitation pick polar in Homer
and I found this pattern of
bi-directional transcription across
these elements that were outside games
so I say okay maybe if I found those
elements I can still run the this
support vector regression model that was
training mammals to identified
transcription regulatory elements
outside the genes I run it I found the
same pattern and now I found 9660 five
elements that were transcribed outside
again having these specific patterns
so they kind of look like enhancers at
the moment so I try to further
characterize them and we had some
methylation that available so I wanted
to blow the methylation on in the three
different contexts around this video
okay this is a and let me explain you a
little bit these graphs goes from 0% to
100% of an element and then 3kv upstream
and 3kv downstream okay this is a random
set of regions across the genome so this
is how methylation loosing cassava in
the CH h context in the CPG context and
in the CH D context this is the pattern
that you observe across genes really low
methylation in the promoter and in the
termination and CPG methylation and
interestingly they the elements that we
found outside genes had this methylation
pattern similar to what is observed in
genes but a little inflated for then I
was interested also in check how
conserve this elements were in my mind
enhancer had to be conserved and I was
kind of wrong so in yellow you see these
are grapes course so basically the
higher the girls for the most concern
those regions are across closely related
species including jatropha flux and
normal so basically use again from 0% to
100% of the feature we're analyzing
yellow is genes super conserve blue is
random sequences and in orange
it was our enhancer can be a genes and
we have served here that they are
actually you have non conserved so I was
a little worried then I
I read this this research was done 2016
I believe where they studied enhancer
evolution across 20 mammalian species
and then found that mammalian a inhale a
enhancers are rapidly evolving sequences
quoting them enhancers are [ __ ] rarely
conserved across these mammals unbiased
mapping leaks candidate enhancers with
lineage-specific positive selection
there's a little bit of evidence on top
of Aryans that this thing that we found
might actually be enhancers and the last
test that we we want to try is okay if
they they the enhancers might be
important to explain a phenotype they
should be explaining more phenotypic
variants in any population for for
example yield components so we we made a
test we have a portion of my genome
invented a host year Calista cassava
genome because a small portion one
percent of the genome is represented by
this enhancer can be a genes what I did
is select all the markers inside here i
LD protected them so any marker Dell
that would have an R square higher than
point nine in a hundred and fifty K
region across then I would just asana
and then I will a build an another
kernel with the rest of the game and I
will compare what I have here with my
new hypothesis of a random set of
markers that have the same distribution
of the enhancer that I found also
protected by a frail D and the second
card and when we found when the when we
run the genomic partitioning and a
percentage of phenotypic variance is
explained for several traits on the
enhancer region some blue to random
reels in orange it is for most of the
trace dry matter contain fresh yield
fruit a number root weight and should
wait they are explaining way more
phenotypic variance than the random sets
the only tray that this is not working
is for CMD and it kind of makes sense
the blue dot is hidden behind but it
makes sense because seeing this is
regulated by both probably a single
locus with a massive QTL well yeah
so yeah the is we've made a case where
we found these these elements outside
genes that are transcribed are not
evolutionary conserved - a specific
methylation pattern and explain more
phenotypic variants that it's random
counterparts so we we kind of think that
this might be enhancers and this will be
a really nice method to identify them in
plants and I think that's it
thank you very much it was a really a
big big big big team efforts when I went
to you land actually I really understood
the effort that is put into getting one
of your data sales are so yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu